Dis: Hi, my name is this, I'm a modification user here at fable
Dis: currently using windows 11 on Apc. And the browser I am using today is the Google Chrome.
Dis: And today I will be testing out this upscale activity on the E fables website here. So let's get started.
Dis: And it looks like I just want to go and complete the rest of my progress here on the introduction to accessibility. So on my keyboard, I'm going to hold windows. Key.
Dis: I just want to mention I am using the screen magnification.
Dis: that's built into the OS. So on the
Dis: keyboard I'm clicking windows key plus sign.
Dis: And right now I'm at 200 300
Dis: and 400.
Dis: So let's go in and look for the my course, and says, right here I am overall progress, 87% complete.
Dis: And I'm gonna click into that. Okay?
Dis: Great
Dis:  I do appreciate people's website, everything scales really? Well, for my magnification.
Dis:  tool. And
okay, just want to read this real quick. Same.
Dis: Okay. everything looks good.
And I am going to click. Continue to learn.
All right.
Dis: Scroll up here.
Dis: about the introductory course.
Dis: Introduction to accessibility scorns great about the Internet Free course.
Dis:  let's see, your experience with accessibility.
Dis: Looks like I'm on the survey right now.
Dis: Can Canada's post experience with accessibility survey help me understand how much you know about accessibility and what you're hoping to learn from this course.
Dis: You know any people with disabilities? The answer is, yes.
Dis: and let me scroll down.
Dis: Okay, so that's that's pretty good. Everything scales really. Well for my modification. And to remind you I am 400 zoomed in right now.
Dis: Let me just read this next one.
Dis: How familiar are you with excessive assistive technology?
Dis: very familiar. Yes.
Dis: Okay. How much do you know about digital accessibility?
Dis: I would say.
Dis: probably third one.
Dis: okay. how often do you encounter digital accessibility at work?
Dis:  probably a few times a week. Sure.
Dis: Okay. And what are the accessibility? Learning goals?
Dis:  to help others. Oh, I like that.
Dis: The snap feature.
Dis: If you saw that when I'm typing, it's mapped to
Dis: where I need to look.
Dis: that's awesome
Dis: to help others
Dis: thick. Very good.
Dis: all right. Let's scroll down and I click, submit. Yep.
Dis: all right, let's see where we're at. Thanks. Your response was submitted. Okay.
Dis:  I think it may I click here? Oh, okay, about engineering course.
Dis: Is that the last one I need to do? Yep. I can't.
Dis:  I don't know what this. Maybe there's some missing content there. But okay, about the engineering course laptops with split screen view codes.
Dis: Yeah, we'll come to accessibility engineering course.
Dis: Evaluate the framework. Okay, skip through this low pay.
Dis:  I just click, finish.
Dis: Okay.
Dis: testing the score alone. Numbers not present. I don't know where to limit is, keep going and watch the numbers
Dis: of char ends in the home. Page 1, 2, 3, 4,
Dis: overall completion. Okay.
Dis: Apologies for to pause. We have some technical difficulties.
Dis: The last model did not pop up. But now we are continuing on the accessibility champions badge page. So
Dis: I am going to windows key on my keyboard and plus sign to zoom in.
Dis: I am 200%, 304% zoomed in. And I'm just gonna look for the the badges.
Dis: I just want to read this real quick. So it's really champions at this level baseline. Now, which about digital accessibility and assistive technology have a strong desire to learn more about how they make and make actions
Dis: accessible products.
Dis: Okay? And then
Dis: here's my badge and a download button is here. Yeah, I mean overall it.
Dis: It fits within my screen notification. I can't complain about the
Dis: about the way it looks. I'm just zooming in a bit more the
Dis: just trying to see.
Dis: So around like.
Dis: let's see, what is this? 500?
Dis: You could see a little bit that the image here gets a little bit blurry.
Dis: and the thought so maybe something to work on to get higher resolution.
Dis: badge And
Dis: I don't know if it's just me could be me. But to download text is
Dis: a bit blurry at 500. Magnificent.
Dis:  I think that's just something to take a look at.
Dis: Yeah. But overall everything else looks pretty good. I'm gonna check out the level 2 here.
Dis: download badge. Yeah.
Dis: And new levels coming soon. Got it?
Dis: Great?
Dis: Well. yeah, I think overall. Everything fits within my screen. Magnification
Dis: things are easy to find always have been on vapable site. So I will. The only thing I would say, is the font on the
Dis: on here is a bit blurry. So getting a higher resolution badge, I think, could help
Dis: with that. because I thought it was my eyeball, but I had to check again. And it it's not so.
Dis: It's actually blurry at 500 magnification.
Dis: So well. I think. and the other thing is
Dis:  I think getting to here and doing the introduction to accessibility. This Gorm course was a fairly simple
Dis:  Everything was scaled well and intuitive. I didn't have a hard time like I didn't have to think about where certain butting layout layouts were on like for some sites.
Dis: So I do appreciate how fable is consistently thinking about.
Dis: you know, people with with disabilities accessing their site and also their courses.
So thank you so much for listening.